[موسيقى]
هي دبابه قتال متوسطه دخلت الخدمه في عام
1938 صنعت منها شركه ميتسوبيشي طرازات
مختلفه لتتناسب مع تطورات الحرب والتحديات
التي واجهت الجيش الياباني اثناء الحرب
الطراز الاول تميز ببرج صغير الحجم ومسلح
بمدفع من عيار 57 مليمتر كان اداؤها جيدا
في الحرب اليابانيه الصينيه الثانيه
[موسيقى]
هذا الفشل دفع اليابان الى انتاج طراز
جديد من هذه الدبابات هذا الطراز مسلح
بمدافع طويله الفوهه ومضاده للدروع من
عيار سبعه واربعين مليمتر نجحت بالفعل في
عمليات الاجتياح الواسعه التي قام بها
الجيش الياباني ضد الفلبين وبورما وكذلك
دول اسيويه اخرى لكن من جديد عادت دبابه
واخفقت في مواجهه الدبابات الامريكيه من
طراز تشيرمان اثناء المعارك البريه
المحدوده على الجزر اليابانيه التي
اجتاحتها الولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]
هذا كان عبر توسيع برجها وزياده تصفيحها
بل وتسليحها بمدفع من عيار 75 ملم لكن
اليابان لم تتمكن من انتاج اكثر من 144
دبابه فقط من هذا الطراز هذا بسبب تدمير
معظم المصانع اليابانيه في الغارات
الامريكيه
[موسيقى]